hi guys I'm here in Warsaw with this
legendary men for those left uh if the
few left in the world who don't know who
you are please can you introduce
yourself hi Luca hi everyone my name is
David I'm The Man Behind the podcast
Italiano which is a project for people
who want to learn Italian where I teach
and talk about the Italian language it's
a YouTube channel it's a podcast it
makes sense since it has podcasts in its
name and I'm not I'm honored to be on
this channel
thank you so let's get into it first of
all what we're gonna do is going to be a
little bit different from the usual
videos that I do with polynomlets
because that it is a public load um I'm
gonna I'm not gonna ask him about why
he's learned the languages he's learned
or how but rather what lesson he's drawn
for each and every one of the languages
that he speaks including his own
language Italian
fantastic fantastic
um
foreign
[Music]
Italian
foreign
okay so
um now let's speak
English uh and good good let's speak
English this way
um so um I know you speak English really
well with this very nice American accent
and thank you thank you man and so my
question is what is the lesson that
you've learned from from learning
English from learning America yeah
um the lesson I thought about is that
you never stop learning a language you
cannot you can learn a language forever
as we were talking about with your
mother tongue you can always improve
your own
native language and the same goes for
any language you can be you know there's
as you were saying my in the video we
shot for my channel there's a there's an
ocean beyond the C2 level you can always
get better you can always learn new
words you can always improve Minor
Details and pronunciations pronunciation
and grammar constructions right so
um you can always get better language
learning
never stops of course you can decide to
stop and be content with the level
you've reached right but it potentially
never stops and uh can be good it can be
bad but in my opinion it can be also an
interesting experience and it's good to
have the mindset to you know to that
you're going to be on this
Journey on this path forever yeah I
believe that an expression that a lot of
people resort to is oh you speak a
language you've heard this before right
and I what does that even mean like it
doesn't mean anything or like a master
language there's no such thing as
mastering a language or speaking a
language perfectly because as Salvador
Lee used to say don't be afraid of
perfection Perfection doesn't exist so
you get into this mindset of I will be a
lifelong learner and that's when you
start appreciating every single moment
and what you know rather than what you
don't yeah this is what I I think
because as we're saying even in your own
native language you can you know there
are different varying levels of
proficiency like if you're talking about
writers you know they're those are
people who know a lot of words and they
speak in a very elegant and eloquent way
so right of course a writer is not going
to have the same level of proficiency as
I don't know a regular person with
regular education so yeah there's a lot
of you know there's a lot of room for
improvement even when you really good at
a language the more you know the more
you know you don't know so that's how it
works exactly exactly and every time
actually I read a book in English a
novel I'm reminded I'm reminded of
how many words I don't know yeah same
here
um
foreign
excellent
[Music]
um
Bueno
[Music]
pero big
ideas
foreign
[Music]
Italian
personas
[Music]
in in is
a personality yes
this is
foreign
Financial
[Music]
I live here I live in
um St Petersburg or in this town
um
[Music]
foreign
okay so
um this is it thank you very much David
can you please tell our audience where
they can find you so they can find me on
YouTube on my website the name is
podcast Italiano
um they can find my podcast on Spotify
or wherever you listen to your podcasts
so pretty much everywhere on Instagram
too that means you're going to I'm Gonna
Leave sorry there's an ambulance here
we're in the center of uh Warsaw and
it's a little bit noisy
um so you can find all the links in the
description box thank you very much I
hope you uh learned useful things and if
you want to leave comments about your
own lessons learning multiple languages
please do leave comments below thank you
very much and talk to you very soon bye
thank you ciao